est-ce que c'est une valeur ajoutée
d'avoir un maire comme moi pour mon
employeur très franchement je ne le
pense pas euh même si j'ai la chance
d'avoir un employeur plutôt conciliant
et euh et auquel bien sûr pourquoi j'ai
demandé si je pouvais devenir maèire
parce que si du du fait que j'ai un
poste à responsabilité je savais que ça
allait poser un problème à l'entreprise
et ça pose un problème à l'entreprise
euh le fait que je sois pas là le lundi
après-midi que je soit pas là le
mercredi après-midi que parfois au
dernier moment à cause des réunions de
communauté urbaines je suis obligée de
changer euh mes demi-journées pour
pouvoir assister à certaines réunions ce
matin il a fallu que je dise à mon
employeur je ne pourrais pas être là
avant 11h ce matin et donc je décale mes
horaires dans la journée donc non je
pense pas que ce soit une valeur ajoutée
très franchement alors oui parfois je
peux faciliter certaines choses quand on
sur port de000 on on pose un permis de
construire ça peut m'arriver de
faciliter les choses avec les services
de l'urbanisme mais très franchement non
c'est pas facilitateur pour l'employeur
parce que il n'a pas son cadre me
concernant à disposition comme il
devrait l'avoir quelque part
objectivement